my girlfriend walked in on me watching a
hardcore porn you should just be like
gross if she walked in on me watching
this it's over she's out the door if you
go on YouTube a lot you might have
noticed that there's a whole world of
video called eye contact practice there
are tons of these videos they're
basically all the same thing a cute
model staring into camera for about five
minutes silently for you to practice I
contact on
[Music]
a lot of them have borderline creepy
names like cute girl looks at you our
model eagerly listens to you but they
seem like they're genuinely trying to
help people and I have problems with eye
contact
I have co-workers who have problems with
eye contact so we're gonna try one of
these videos and see if they actually
help I'm really bad at eye contact
especially when I'm talking to people
who are very good at eye contact when I
make eye contact with people I just feel
like I need to look away I'm a big dude
so if I give eye contact I feel like the
other person is intimidated by me I'm
gonna get eaten alive in helmets he's
intimidating completely frees up going
on dates it can be very awkward I feel
like I'm being rude I feel like it holds
me back a little bit I think it would
benefit me to be better at it so I'm
gonna click on this video and see what
happened hello nice to meet you
you got me nice smile this is really
hard like I feel like I'm embarrassed
it's kind of intimate in a way this is
more difficult than I thought it would
be her makeup has done very well your
makeup has done very well she nodded I
feel like I'm actually doing better than
I thought
just cuz it is a video it's not somebody
who's actually here
this for me doesn't feel awkward this is
something I could handle I think I might
be into this I kind of want to do this
again okay so it's been about one week
since we tried these eye contact to
practice videos after we shut the video
none of us were that impressed I'm not
sure that I'm cured I feel like I would
have to watch several videos like this
to get to that level of comfort but then
off camera
right after we all noticed an immediate
difference now that like before I said
that this couldn't help someone but I
have to take my words back I'm saying
bring your eyes but I want to look
directly at you no I don't know what you
did to me
it's like even talking to me right now
you're making more eye contact are you
yeah it actually helped that immediate
comfort reaction definitely wore off I
was better at eye contact the day we
practice but there are a few days have
gone by and you can see I'm still
struggling right now it's a gradual
process I think it's not something that
anybody can just like get over right
away from watching one video but I'm now
thinking more about it and trying
actively correct yeah me too say it I'm
gonna look for other means of eye
contact practice maybe I'll find you one
day and I'll just come up to you and
just stare at you for 30 seconds I
really think that if you have serious
anxiety around making eye contact and
you have a job interview or you have a
date that you're nervous about I
actually recommend making eye contact
with the weird stranger lady for five
full minutes because there really was an
immediate change and it couldn't hurt so
thank you YouTube I'm not weird anymore
yeah